[Musique]
oh
jean marie muller bonjour bonjour vous
recevons aujourd'hui pour une chaîne
youtube qui s'appelle singer view vous
êtes philosophe spécialisé dans des
mouvements non violents là des
complications comme disent nos amis
russes par la non violence
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
votre secteur d'activité
alors c'est vrai la vie que j'étais
philosophe c'est à dire je suis un ami
de la sagesse au sens étymologique du
mot et c'est vrai que j'identifie la
sagesse et la non violence je suis un
ami de la non violence
alors j'écris des livres parieurs mais
l'essentiel c'est ma réflexion sur la
violence
à partir d'une critique radicale de la
violence qui m'amène à parler donc de
non violence raconte on parle de non
violence on passe à gandhi et c'est vrai
que gandillet a été à la fois un
philosophe à stratège un artisan de la
non violence
et il ya un avant et un après gantillon
ce qui concerne la non violence parce
que c'est vrai que le mot de non
violence apparaît encore trop souvent
négatif non violence
parce que nous avons une perception
positive de la violence - par plus donne
moins je crois qu'il faut justement
avoir une position une perception
négative de la violence ce qui fait que
le mot non violent devient positif mois
par mois donne plus je crois que la
violence est précisément le le viol de
de l'humanité de l'homme je dirais
d'abord le viol de celui qui exerce la
violence et bi de celui qui la subit
je pense donc il faut en effet
contrairement à
l'idéologie qui domine notre société
récuser radicalement la violence comme
étant
je te vends la négation même des valeurs
d'humanité
ce que vous entendez par non violence
est ce que vous êtes intéressé ou
travaux de krishnamurti
de longs à dix ans de loin qu'est-ce que
vous avez caresser de ces travaux
pas suffisamment pour en parler si vous
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliciter
votre propre définition de l'agressivité
alors c'est vrai je crois que trop
souvent on assimile l'agressivité à la
violence c'est pour ça aussi que le mode
non violence est discrédité car ce
serait le refus de l'agressivité on
l'agressivité c'est une
composante de notre humanité
je préfère à la lithologie latine at
grady avancer vers avancé ibères je dois
avancer vers l'autre pour
simplement affirmer mes droits
m'affirmer et je pense que donc
l'agressivité est un moment nécessaire
du conflit là encore je crois il faut
réhabiliter le conflit réhabiliter la
grée tibi qu'est ce que vous entendez
par confier ce que vous pouvez nous
définir votre perception votre
définition du conflit nous sommes des
êtres de relation et bien sûr l'idéal
que c'est que la relation à l'autre aux
hôtes soient fondés sur sur la confiance
mais très souvent elles et qu'au
contraire fondée sur la défiance dans un
premier temps je me défie de l'autre
donc je suis en conflit avec lui le
conflit c'est aussi le moment où je vais
pouvoir construire ma relation à l'autre
et justement pour cela je dois mettre en
oeuvre mon agressivité et
me confronter à l'agressivité de l'ôter
trouver un compromis et qui me permettra
de trouver une relation avec l'autre
constructive qu'est ce que vous entendez
par bienveillance
alors là encore je me référais
facilement à l'étymologie
la bienveillance eux c'est je crois
manifester justement de la bonté
vis-à-vis de l'autre
là encore nous sommes peut-être souvent
tentés par la malveillance que l'autre
qui est différent de nous et avec lequel
nous avons justement trop de différence
donc la bienveillance et je crois là
encore dans la construction de namas
relation à l'autre établir des liens qui
vont faire que je pourrai
construire ma personnalité et vivre dans
dans la paix finalement c'est ça aussi
le l'enjeu du conflit c'est c'est vivre
en paix avec l'aude et en paix avec moi
même
en début d'interview vous nous expliquer
que notre société
vous est peut-être un culte à la
violence et comment vous l'expliquez
si vous voulez c'est c'est tout là la
tradition je crois de notre société avec
la la composante militaire aussi bon
on a trop souvent je crois lier
l'affirmation de du peuple de la nation
aux données militaires c'est
significatif que le 14 juillet par
exemple on fait défiler l'armée bon et
et non pas par exemple les bergers ou où
les intellectuels
il ya une militarisation de notre
culture qui fait que là encore c'est à
travers la violence que nous pensons
qu'il faut construire
la paix finalement et c'est construire
la paix comme on quels sont vos
préconisations concrètes alors la paix
c'est précisément maîtriser le conflit
avec l'autre établi une relation de
bienveillant de bonté avec l'autre et en
sachant qu'elle sera toujours remise en
question mon il s'agit là non violence
c'est pas un idéaliste et pas idéaliser
ma relation à l'autre est l'effet de
difficultés mais je crois que la paix la
paix c'est une relation pacifiée avec
l'autre où je peux maîtriser le conflit
et établir une relation constructive qui
va faire que je pourrai affirmé ma
personnalité respectée la personnalité
de l'autre comment vous conjuguez sain
dans un climat de guerre économique
alors bon c'est vrai que l'économie est
aussi conflictuelle
et qu' il s'agira là encore d'essayer de
maîtriser les conflits pour arriver à
une situation de de relations pacifiées
alors la guerre économique elle est dans
les rapports économiques que je peux
avoir bois ou que notre société a avec
les autres sociétés et là encore je
crois qu'il faudra toujours accepté le
conflit accepter les difficultés à
accepter les les bons les conflits et
puis toujours les maîtriser et arriver à
une pacification à une paix économique
vous n'avez pas connu la guerre
alors
j'ai quelques souvenirs de la première
guerre de la deuxième guerre mondiale je
suis non 39 bon donc j'ai le souvenir d
habiter un petit village à côté d'eux ou
l'est j'ai souvenir de de l'armée
allemande qui a envahi le village et
puis ensuite l'armée américaine qui a
envahi le village donc j'ai des
souvenirs relativement précis tu te
crois pas avoir été traumatisée si vous
voulez pas par la guerre
mais j'ai des souris j'ai des images si
vous voulez 2 de la guerre et puis alors
bon plus concrètement j'ai été confronté
à la guerre d'algérie
j'étais confronté mon de manière d'abord
un direct et en étudiant j'avais la
guerre d'algérie comme horizon à travers
le service militaire et
le fait que finalement j'ai décidé de
faire
l'école des officiers
pourquoi bon il me semblait que
puisqu'il fallait
quand même aller à l'armée autant avoir
des responsabilités
donc j'ai fait
quatre mois de classe 6 mois d'école
d'officiers et je serai en algérie au
moment du cessez-le-feu donc je n'ai pas
eu à faire l'expérience de la guerre
j'ai vu simplement les conséquences de
la guerre en algérie les conséquences
entre les différentes communautés et je
crois que c'était important dans mon
cheminement vers la non violence car je
me suis j'ai pris conscience que la
violence que la guerre ne permettait pas
d'apporter des solutions constructives
au conflit et que là encore la violence
mettait en place des éléments de
contradictions qu'il fallait essayer de
dépasser savait déjà rencontré l'abbé
pierre oui oh oui je m'aime buire est
connu l'abbé pierre oui
sa perception de la violence mais on
parle et non violent quand on se
rencontrait souvent la passe est ce
parce qu'il ya quatre jours ensemble
dans un un congrès je ne sais plus dans
quel pays d'europe du nord
il acceptait cette problématique de la
non violence
il n'a pas populariser à proprement
parler là non violent mais son son
action se voulait non violente est elle
se voulait aussi par rapport aux
conflits de ce qu'ils étaient victimes
de la violence économique sociale
arrivé à à leur donner confiance et à
perm est là encore une solution non
violente des conflits
est-ce que vous pensez que la catatonie
émotionnel des pays occidentaux face à
la pauvreté la misère et leur
consommation irraisonnée est une forme
de violence a certainement qu'elle
engendre des violences certainement que
la civilisation occidentale
profitent des violences sur beaucoup de
pays au niveau de notre consommation
notamment bon on est tous partisans on
est tous compromis dans ces violences et
encore je crois que il s'agit de faits
de prendre conscience de ces violences
et puis tenter par des choix personnels
qui seront pas suffisants mais qui sont
nécessaires je suis déjà moi
responsable de mes choix au quotidien et
je crois que à ce moment là j'ai une
possibilité tout de même d'avoir une
influence même si je crois qu'il faut
toujours avoir une dimension collective
donc politique si je vous dis la
violence et la force des faibles et
commence où s'arrête les connaissances
est ce que vous pensez pas qu'on est
entouré d'une bande de crétins
or je me méfierais d'avoir un jugement
aussi
négatif sur l'ensemble
de mes compatriotes de mes voisins
congénères de mes congénères
je crois que là
l'idéologie de la violence est une forme
de crétinerie si vous voulez me faire
dire cela je le dis volontiers je les
assume bon
c'est vrai que la la la la viola
l'idéologie de love qui fait que ont
spontanément on pense que la violence
elle est la norme de nos relations
ne permet pas vivre ensemble harmonieux
et dans la bienveillance dont je pense
qu'il faut que nous puissions aussi la
prendre conscience et rompre je crois
que la notion de rupture
avec l'idéologie dominante est une
dimension essentielle de la non-violence
est ce que l'idéologie dominante qui
active les pulsions les plus prix les
plus primaires de nos cerveaux est ce
que cette idéologie n'a pas je vais
reformuler ma phrase est-ce que c'était
ce que ça n'est pas un dessin qu'on
active les pulsions les plus primaires
chez les gens pour mieux les manipuler
probablement que ça fait partie d'un
ensemble
d'autant plus que
souvent nous nous avons un discours sur
la violence sans avoir une grande
pratique de la violence nous n'avons pas
généralement de
responsabilité très précises dans les
violents ou alors au niveau économique
mais nous nous l'ignorons alors je crois
qu'il faudrait en effet que y ait cette
prise de conscience qui amène une
rupture par rapport à cette idéologie et
puis donc cette possibilité de dépasser
cette idéologie cette pratique par une
culture de la non violence
cette rupture que vous concevez ce
qu'elle devra passer par un événement
exotiques fédérateurs tels une
catastrophe une guerre
au jeu n'est pas de
de sympathie particulière pour cette
problématique qui est parfois évoqué
d'abord parce que j'irai nous avons déjà
donné est ce que la société n'est pas un
immature
pour caresser ses valeurs non violente
certainement certainement qu'elle est
mature mais quand vous parliez de
catastrophe nous en avons tous les jours
des catastrophes à la télévision dans
les informations tous les jeux nous
avons des catastrophes qui montre
justement
l'impossibilité de la violence a créé
une société de paix et pourtant c'est
vrai que nous ne prenons pas les nous
n'en tirons pas les conséquent ne nous
prenons pas les décisions qui
permettrait d'éviter de retomber
toujours dans ce piège quelles sont ses
décisions je crois justement c'est
d'abord une prise de conscience de ces
violences qui ne permettent pas de
construire la paix et puis d'imaginer
d'abord au niveau de la pensée puis
autant que faire se peut au niveau de la
stratégie au début de l'action quelles
sont les possibilités de résolution non
violente des conflits je vois que la non
violence est à la fois une pensée une
philosophie est une stratégie d'action
si je vous dis heureux les simples
d'esprit aujourd'hui j'ai compris
[Musique]
alors ça fait 2000 on que c'est écrit
oui certainement mais il ya beaucoup de
choses qui ont été écrites ya 2000 ans
d'ailleurs mais quand il commet beaucoup
de conneries oui mais il comprit que
justement la violence n'est pas la bonne
solution
je crois qu'il ya une simplicité
d'esprit en effet dans l'acceptation de
la violence dans le le fait de croire
que la violence permet là la vie
ensemble alors qu'elle elle détruits au
contraire la vie ensemble il faut il
faut en passer par l'acceptation de
l'autre ah oui bien sûr bien sûr mais je
crois que les septs ation de l'autre
peut se faire aussi dans la résolution
du conflit dans la paix j'ai besoin de
l'autre je n'imagine pas vivre dans la
solitude donc je crois que l'acceptation
de l'autre est un élément majeur de la
construction de ma personnalité de la
construction de mon moi donc je crois
que bien sûr la relation à l'autre est
tout à fait essentiel une question
d'internet est-ce que vous avez des
exemples de stratégie non violente
à bas tout de même tout de même à
commencer par gandhi si vous voulez bon
qu'on connaît mal d'ailleurs parce qu'on
on a fait un sage mais
la gandhi a mis en place d'une stratégie
de résistance
pour libérer la ddt
de la domination britannique bon
il a notamment refusé
d'obéir aux lois je crois que l'une des
dimensions de la stratégie l'action non
violente c'est la non coopération
en fait nous coopérons avec l'injustice
nous coopérons avec les laumes injuste
et l'action non-violente la rupture j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure c'est souvent le
fait de désobéir aux lois injustes d
obéir à l'ordre injuste alors il ya
aussi martin luther king tout de même
qui a été
décisif obama s'est toujours déclaré le
fils de martin luther king le fait qu'à
noir d'avesnes président des états unis
c'était inimaginable un bond de l'action
martin luther king et là encore martin
luther king c'est à la fois
spirituelle bon chrétien mais bon après
tout c'est vrai que le christianisme est
fondamentalement violon une ouverture
vers la non violence et que lorsqu'il a
été violent c'était par une une
reniement des valeurs spirituelles du
christianisme les croisades ben oui mais
justement les croisades les guerres
saintes ont été rudement total de la
spiritualité évangélique et des hommes
que martin luther king justement ont
rompu avec toute cette ses traditions de
violence de l'histoire du christianisme
pour affirmer qu en effet c'était dans
la résistance non violente dans la lutte
non-violente qu'il était possible
d'incarner le critère ni dans l'histoire
vous avez vu barack obama recevoir le
prix nobel de la paix ce président
américain qui a plus bombardés que bush
est ce que le prix nobel de la paix
c'est pas une sucette ou une médaille
comme une autre alors elle peut ne pas
l'être si vous voulez vraiment le
paradoxe est que barack obama a reçu le
prix nobel parce qu'il avait fait une
déclaration contre la course aux
armements nucléaires
quelques temps avant bond est de toute
évidence il n'a pas été fidèle à ses
déclarations
et
le dernier prix nobel de la paix qui va
être rendu lé ces jours ci c'est
justement pour icahn à l'international
de résistance à l'armé nucléaire
donc le masne le mouvement pour une
alternative non violente dont je suis
l'un des fondateurs
fait partie prenante de l'attribution de
ce prix non je pense qu'en même temps
quand on voit la martin luther king a eu
le prix nobel de la paix il ya il ya eu
quand même des prix nobel de la paix qui
ont mérité cette qualification
alors bon tout dépend encore une fois
qu'elle est l'itinéraire de ce qu'ils
n'ont qu'ils ont et les décisions qui
sont prises après comment
krishnamurthy pour revenir à lui reçu la
médaille de la paix des nations unies
d'ailleurs il a oublié sur la table il a
mis là il a même pas reçues il n'a même
pas voulu il a fait son discours et la
partie après vous vous avez reçu la
médaille de gandhi par la main du
président indien ouais il avait les
codes nucléaires dans la poche le
président indien alors comment voir
comment accepter ce genre de distinction
alors justement je me suis posé la
question
en fait c'était j'ai reçu ce prix
d'une association indienne qui se
réfèrent précisément à gandhi
le prix que j'ai reçu c'était pour la
diffusion des idées gandhi en dehors de
l'inde en dehors de l'inde ben non je ne
savais pas qu au départ c'était le
président de la république allait me
remettre ce prix bon je les jeux les
appris après coup
alors c'est vrai que il avait la clef de
la dissuasion nucléaire dans sa poche
donc il y avait une contradiction mais
encore une fois
qui me semblait important c'était de me
situer par rapport à aux indiens qui
sont fidèles à gandhi aujourd'hui
dissuasion nucléaire c'est encore un
sens
alors bon le sens qu'on veut lui donner
c'est d'arriver à a créé
une situation de de
neutraliser la
larme les armes nucléaires
personnellement je pense qu'il faut
rompre totalement avec cette
problématique parce que
d'autres alizés les hommes nucléaire de
son adversaire alors oui de son
adversaire bon c'est le but de la
dissuasion bon
je crois que en même temps la dissuasion
est fondée sur la préméditation d' un
crime contre l'humanité et je pense donc
il faut récuser radicalement la
dissuasion nucléaire
bon
d'autant plus que le risque d'un
dérapage est toujours possible
actuellement enfants de dépensons des
milliards et des milliards chaque année
et ça va augmenter dans les années qui
viennent autour de trois meilleurs temps
où pour eux c'était trois meilleurs
parents savate ça va doubler dans les
années qui viennent
il ya toujours ce problème de la
modernisation espèce de fuite en avant
vers une des armes nucléaires de plus en
plus moderne dit on donc je crois que
c'est véritablement
une
renoncement à toute pensée un
renoncement à toute
civilisation est
malheureusement là encore la bombe à la
l'opinion public s'habitue et
ce se compromet a accepté cette cette
problématique est ce qu'il n'est pas
trop tard pour que l'opinion publique
prennent conscience des choses par
rapport à la crise climatique la crise
économique la crise sociale la crise
humanitaire est ce que l'opinion
publique occidentale
n'a encore le bagage intellectuel pour
appréhender ce qui se passe je veux le
croire je veux le quoi il n'y a pas de
fatalité il n'y a pas de fatalité ni
dans un sens ni dans un autre je crois
que par exemple sur le problème
climatique il ya une certaine prise de
conscience qui se fait
et certaines décisions qui sont prises
non il n'est pas trop tard je pense que
parmi les nouvelles générations il y a
tout de même aussi des associations qui
se craignent dans la société civile les
kills bon bah je pense par exemple à
hasnon violent 21 bons des associations
d'écologie les nom m'échappe ted mais
nous sommes le match commence à avoir
une certaine antériorité mais boulbon
prenez un thé hâtivement viol mais
beaucoup de jeunes maintenant se
retrouvent dans cette problématique de
la non-violence et
bon espérons par exemple que les
le christianisme devrait pouvoir quand
même encore retrouvé le sens
de l'évangile est par exemple le fait
que
les évêques qui sont les porte-parole de
la communauté chrétienne
s'accommode de la dissuasion nucléaire
c'est une trahison totale est ce que
c'est une fatalité non on peut tout de
même envisager en effet que que les
évêques prennent position contre l'armé
nucléaire et puis les autres
spiritualité dont je ne renonce pas pour
ma part encore à ce qu' il n'y ait une
convergence de l'ensemble des
spiritualités pour affirmer justement
les valeurs de paix et de non violence
quand vous avez regardé récemment les
manifestations or au bourg à paris on
voit un mouvement énergie qui
s'appellait black blocks
des jeunes qui s'organisent pour
affronter la police ou affrontez les
violences de la police selon le prisme
de lecture
sur lequel on se base votre avis sur ces
jeunes est ce que c'est une violence
légitime par rapport à la violence qu'on
leur imposait ce que ce type de
raisonnement est encore viable d'imposer
une violence légitime non je ne pense
pas qu'elle est légitime tant que la
viande est jamais légitime l ai jamais
légitime est toujours illégitime
fondamentalement des contraires aux
exigences de la loi de la loi de
l'humanité qu'est ce qu'ils doivent
faire une grève de la faim ce soir dans
la police mais tout nu avec du ketchup
sur la tête de carrick arrêtons pas là
l'action non violente en fait dans quand
on parle des black blocks il ya souvent
des manifestations c'est souvent dans le
cas des manifestations qui sont non
violente si je mens pas grave notre dame
des landes
la majorité
pense qu'effectivement c'est dans
l'action non violente parfois dans
l'action de désobéissance là encore
parce que là la violences des black
blocks ne pourra jamais
faire taire la violence de la police
c'est forcément l'échec et puis alors ce
qui est très important aussi c'est que
dans l'action publique l'important c'est
la réception par l'opinion publique or
l'opinion publique ne peut pas être
à accepter la violence la violence des
deux jours une contradiction pour
l'opinion publique le mes voisins mais
ne ne peux pas accepter la violence donc
je crois qu'il en même temps la violence
de contestation se contredit elle-même
et je crois que ya beaucoup de
résistance justement actuellement de non
violent même si le mot n'est pas employé
peu importe après tout mais
là
l'action de non violente l'action même
là là l'action de paix collective par
rapport à la police reid être beaucoup
plus efficaces que les quelques
violences que l'on peut faire contre
elle
récemment il ya un fab lab un lieu
associatif qui a été incendié
pour des revendications
nébuleuses
votre avis sur ce type d'action plus
particulière est ce qu'un attentat
peut résoudre les choses
a espéré pas que j'ai répondu oui quand
même
la tante me fais l'avocat du diable oui
je vois mais mais mais le diable est
toujours une mauvaise cause
croyons en dieu
pas de l'être est-ce que vous avez un
ami imaginaire est ce que j'ai un ami
imaginaire
bon la croyance en dieu et
n'est pas simple ce que ce que je crois
c'est qu'il y a des des exigences qui
ne sont pas sûrs naturel car ils sont
contraints très enracinée dans notre
nature mais je crois que la la la la
transcendance si vous voulez de de
l'homme qui peut aussi s'affirmer par la
non violence est quelque chose
d'essentiel alors dieu existe ou pas
j'en sais trop rien finalement je je ne
définirai pas comme athée par ailleurs
mais ce qui me semble essentiel c'est
que dès lors que l'on parle
d'une vie de transcendance je crois
qu'il ya une
possibilité
nécessité de parler de non violence
quand on parle de transcendance
une question internet pour revenir à
notre sujet précédent comment établir un
lien bienveillant avec un cordon de crs
alors posé comme ça il n'y a pas de
possibilité
il reste que malgré tout les les crs en
des hommes sont des humains si vous
voulez et je pense que quelque part ils
sont capables aussi d'être conscient des
exigences de la paix et donc des
contradictions du métier qu'ils exercent
go leur fait faire donc je crois que
j'ai été confrontée à plusieurs reprises
à des crs à des eaux qu'elle dit est ce
qui ressemblait les militaires que
maintenu dopé aux stéroïdes au coût de
la dernière fois c'était lors des des
quatre jours de grève de la faim nous
avons fait à paris contre les armes
nucléaires avons voulu manifester devant
le ps et on a on a eu des cordons de crs
et autour de nous j'ai dialogué avec eux
on peut dialoguer avec eux non il n'ya
pas de là encore il n'y a pas de
fatalité ya pas d que vous avez des
hommes en face de vous il ya toujours
cette possibilité d'établir le lien de
la parole et de la communication dont
non violente face à l'intelligence
artificielle des robot tueur comme on ah
le robot tueur il parle pas à lui ne
comprend pas donc on va pas prétendre
que le robot tueur peut devenir non
violent mais celui qui est l'acteur dur
boss lui qui prend la décision
l'accord peut aussi être ouvert aux
contradictions de la violence vous
entendez qui par l'acteur dur au bout le
pouvoir politique a le seul détenteur de
la violence légitime non pas légitime
légale pas légitime légale bon alors
bien sûr que quelque part c'est l'état
nous avons défini l'état comme étant
justement la soude de la violence
prétendument légitime elle n'est que
légal bon et c'est vrai que là aussi
c'est une contradiction de nos sociétés
de vouloir croire que la violence va
être le moyen privilégié de résoudre les
conflits sociaux et politiques qu'est ce
que vous pensez de la la violence des
médias ce soft power qui est plaqué sur
les populations qu'est ce que vous
préconisez pour reprendre le contrôle
des médias ce que je préconise c'est de
pouvoir m'exprimer à travers les médias
ce que je fais tout de même depuis
quelques années et si j'ai
50 ans de vie militante derrière moi je
n'ai pas à me plaindre par ailleurs des
médias qui m'ont souvent donné la parole
alors voilà
là la non violence peut aussi être reçu
par les médias et peut s'exprimer à
travers les médias je ne peux pas faire
l'économie des médias
votre question d'internet que je vais
essayer de reformuler la violence de
prendre et elles pas racine dans
l'éducation et la communication
communication non-violence égale plus
efficace efficace qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la violence de la parole
politique
mais là encore on est dans un schéma
culturel finalement bon c'est la culture
de la violence qui fait que la parole
politique souvent va justifier les
différentes violences
parfois même justifier des violences qui
prétendent se lutter contre d'autres
violences c'est vrai qu'il ya là toute
une
engrenage finalement mais qui n'est pas
non plus une fatalité ne nous ne sommes
pas
absolument emprisonné dans cet engrenage
et donc dans la possibilité d'y résister
vous connaissez le collège interarmées
de défense à paris ouais maintenant il
s'appelle école de guerre ouais comment
vous expliquer ce changement de
sémantique bon bah c'est un retour au
change
ça retour aux sources la halle à l'école
de guerre a toujours été
l'appellation contrôlée si vous voulez
mon même si on prenait d'aidé alors oui
ben c'est vrai que l'armée a pour but de
faire la guerre alors que elle devrait
avoir pour but et c'est probablement
aussi quelque chose qui est
conscient dans la main pour but de
charles ap oui mais par la préparation
de la guerre civile sympa mais l'homme
voit la bomba donc nous y sommes et je
crois que c'est pas si vis pacem para ap
hm
il ya des moyens pacifiques de préparer
la paix de pouvoir créer des liens de
rencontres compréhension avec les autres
et je crois que en même temps c'est
quelque chose qui existe
il n'y a pas et il n'y a pas que que la
guèye a pas que la même si bon par
rapport à pour terrorisme on en arrive à
penser qu' on est dans une logique
infernale de de violence je crois qu ils
vont peut pas faire la guerre contre le
terrain de terrorisme n'est pas la
guerre par ledit n'est pas la guerre le
théorie c'est des actions individuelles
qui sont faites sur notre territoire la
guerre c'est au contraire une action
collective
justement préparer organiser et je ne
fais pas la guerre contre le terrorisme
que je peux c'est là encore toujours
récusé l'idée au logis qui
nourrit le terrorisme et je crois que là
aussi il ya trop de jeunes qui peuvent
être sensibles à la problématique du
terrorisme et il faut pouvoir
dissoudre cette idéologie
10 août cette idéologie ça veut dire
aussi peut-être combattre notre propre
novlangue comme la guerre contre le
terrorisme les frappes chirurgicales
qu'est-ce qu'on fait par rapport à la
novlangue que la population subit tous
les jours par ses communicants et ben je
crois que là aussi c'est une résistance
qui doit être menée par chacun d'entre
nous même s'il faudra toujours trouver
des lieux de
d'affirmations collective on n'est pas
dans le désert absolu non plus à ce
niveau là il ya tout de même nom dans
notre société a tout de même d'aider des
repères pour parler d'eux qu'est ce qui
nous reste me repère à bas tout de même
même pas le christianisme nous avons dit
tout à l'heure qu'il était souvent
nier par le biais de gide la violence il
peut aussi nourrir une conviction de non
violence
donc il n'ya pas non plus de 2 de
fatalité à ce niveau-là et
bon je veux croire que
il y aura de plus en plus ces
convergences des différences de
spiritualité vers la non violence
vous connaissez votre audience sur
internet non proche du néant
oh je ne suis pas sûr je ne suis pas sûr
j'ai des retours qui me permettraient
non pas de faire du triomphalisme mais
d'une heure non je reçois de nombreuses
invitations jour joie de nombreux
retours proche du néant parce que non
pas à cause de moi mais parce que je
crois tout de même que que la non
violence
peut
recueillir un assentiment
j'interviens dans des lycées par dc
d'orléans bon puisque j'habite sur rien
d'ailleurs je félicite les derniers
liens qui vous ont posé des questions et
ben voilà donc on n'est pas non plus là
encore dans le désert
cognitif et intellectuelle oui quand
vous regardez par exemple la télé
réalité les tv là ce que ce n'est pas un
désert
ça existe aussi ça existe aussi mais
encore désert n'est pas
plus envahissant à notre époque à la
vôtre
aubin l'époque c'est encore la mienne
aujourd'hui non mais
je ne suis pas sûr enfin je n'entre pas
dans ce pessimisme si vous voulez ou
surréalisme je ne suis pas sûr parce que
le réalise et aussi voir toutes les
possibilités
que j'arrive tout de même à apercevoir
de pouvoir
introduire cette réflexion sur la non
violence de ce mois du lat encore une
fois je me situe pas dans une
problématique de pessimisme de
d'optimisme
pessimisme décidé d'abaisser leurs oeufs
l'optimiste est aussi bon le réalisme
c'est précisément de voir les
possibilités réelles et qui existe à mon
avis de pouvoir faire valoir les
exigences de la non violence parce que
précisément il ya aussi tout de même au
delà de la deûle influence qu'elle peut
avoir cette théologie de la viola il ya
tout de même aussi des résistances qui
se font jour
question d'internet un système pyramidal
verticale comme le capitalisme peut-il
être mon violon alors capital et non
violent non bien sûr bon
alors maintenant est-ce qu'il peut être
combattue par la non violence oui gens
n'auront pas de mal comment comment ben
je dirai au jour le jour où on niveau
même de mon existant dans mes choix
personnels dans le boycott alors le
bruit code tout à fait tout à fait je
pense que il ya par exemple une action
de boycott qui doit être organisée alors
je peux moi refuser d'acheter tel
produit parce que j'estime que il est
lié à une problématique d'injustice mais
vous qu'est ce que vous pensez du bds
alors je leur parlais bien d'en parler
mais si je fais un refus individuel la
voisine qui est derrière moi elle va
acheter le produit que j'ai refusé
d'acheter donc ça sera pas efficace donc
il faut s'organiser alors justement le
le boycott désinvestissements
bon
permet par rapport au produit
qui sont faits en palestine par l'état
d'israël qui sont vendus sur le marché
est en ciel par l'état d'israël je crois
que c'est le bds a été inaugurée par des
palestiniens et je pense qu'il faut
absolument que nous puissions mieux nous
organiser alors malheureusement le bds a
été reconnu comme étant quelque sorte
illégale par là le pouvoir français
c'est aberrant ils ont ils ont légiféré
pour interdire oui alors bien sûr nous
ne faisons que que
dépasser cette interdiction
j'en parle en public j'en parle et il
n'y a donc pas m'arrêter demain matin et
s'il venait après tout pourquoi pas je
suis prêt à vous apporter des songes oui
par exemple et puis ça pas portera aussi
un peu plus de publicité pourquoi pas
donc je crois que effectivement le
boycott est un élément essentiel
d'un citoyen responsable au niveau de
ses choix de consommation et d'achat
bien sûr qu'est ce que vous pensez de
l'immolation pour des question
d'engagement politique
alors s'il faut répondre par oui ou par
non je suis contre je suis content
l'immolation qui est tout de même
davantage une je crois peut-être une
idée une attitude de désespoir je ne
pense pas avec l'immolation pour créer
l'espoir
on peut risquer la mort de ce rêve
peut-être que par une grève de la faim
illimitée et là je peux y croire je peux
y penser mais l'immolation non j'avoue
que je pense que c'est contre indiquée
totalement à tous points de vue c'est
une forme de grève de la faim plus
rapide qu'elle croit pas je ne crois pas
je ne crois pas parce que l'ajustement
vous prenez la décision seul dans la
guerre de la fin je je je prends des
risques mais je ne prends jamais la
décision de mourir
elle peut être la conséquence d'une
grève de la faim qui échoue encore que
si je prends le la mordent dans une
grève de la faim elle peut avoir aussi
elle même sa fécondité
alors que la fécondité de l'immolation
j'avoue que je suis sceptique forme de
sacrifice
oui mais j'avoue que je n'y crois pas
on vous écoute autre question d'internet
faudrait-il raconter l'histoire à
l'école à travers la non violence plutôt
que par les guerres là bien sûr parce
que la réponse est dans la question
bien évidemment bien évidemment il est
essentiel que nous puissions n'ont pas
oublié les gars n'ont pas
faire en sorte qu'elles n'ont pas existé
mais je crois qu'il est essentiel que
les jeunes puissent être ouverts à cette
ces problématiques de nom viola mieux
étudier gandhi napoléon si vous voulez
me faire dire les choses clairement
clausewitz où napoléon
by claude vite lui il a il a surtout
théorisé
et
en même temps bon la guerre est une
politique et je crois que en même temps
c'est la négation de la politique et est
ce que là est ce que la guerre est un
art
on pourrait le dire si vous voulez on
pourrait le dire que la guerre est un
art mais c'est un art
totalement dérisoire bon
on peut toujours construire en effet des
stratégies militaires des stratégies
guerrières qui auront leur efficacité
mais je pense que le bilan des guerres
et de mai est tout de même totalement
désespérant est-ce que vous avez des
ouvrages a conseillé notre communauté
au fait que l' ouvrage qui que jeu le
plus vendu c'est le dictionnaire de la
non violence
je crois que en effet les mots ont leur
importance il s'agit de redonner aux
mots une rue située dans une culture de
la non-violence
déconstruire tout la culture de la
violence ça se fait aussi à travers un
langage inventé un langage la non
violence je crois que c'est essentiel
tout à fait finie c'est ma phrase les
montrent un sens ont enlevé le samson
moore rajoute de la misère sur le monde
chez les mouche un sens ont enlevé le
sens des mots un joutes de la misère sur
le monde
s'agit pas d'enlever le sens des mots il
s'agit de donner au mot le sens qu'ils
ont et de voir qu'est ce qu'il justifie
les lélés
moque sur la guerre ont un sens mais je
crois que je m'en dans la mesure où ils
auraient tendance à rendre la guerre
fatale il faut l'aider construire c'est
beau aussi et construire donc une
culture de la non violence avec des mots
donc construit une culture du mou
or je crois qu'une culture du mot
peut-être pas parce que le encore une
fois le tout dépend ce que le mot dit
est ce que le mot veut dire donc je
maintiens une culture de la non violence
à travers les modes la non violence
quand vous voyez ces maudits qui
travestissent notre longue pour faire
passer des slogans publicitaires ou des
choses comme ça
comment le peuple peut s'endurcir face à
ça
mais je crois d'abord c'est toujours
pareil c'est une prise de conscience
qu'il faut prendre il faut faire par
rapport à 7 il n'y a pas plus aveugle
que celui qui ne veut pas voir
certainement certainement mais il n'ya
pas nos plus là je crois de fatalité
les les individus les citoyens ne sont
pas totalement aveugle je ne le crois
pas non je ne crois pas il ya une
possibilité tout de même de voir le ch
comment ils sont lâches
pas uniquement fin unique maintenant
mais je crois qu'à une dialectique les
volets je ne vous ferai pas sortir de la
dialectique et une dialectique c'est à
dire que nous avons en effet la
tentation de subir la tentation d'être
complice mais il ya aussi au delà de
cette tentation la possibilité
de résister et par conséquent de créer
une autre voie que la voie qu'ils
voudraient nous être dictée qu'est ce
que vous pensez que pensez-vous de la
communication non-violente théorisée par
marshall rosenberg je suis pour le bruit
pense que la communication non violente
et qui veut mettre en avant précisément
le langage l'annoncions la pratique de
la non violence
donc il faut toujours
conjugué à la fois le langage et la
pratique la culture et la stratégie et
tout ce qui est culture de la non
violence va dans le bon sens bien sûr
peut-on tête mon violon lorsque
l'institution judiciaire est en échec
autrement dit la non violence est elle
possible son justice
alors là la non violence elle a pour but
précisément de créer la justice
et que la l'institution judiciaire dans
un pays
qui trop souvent d'hab peut-être en
effet utiliser la violence bon
la peine de mort étant le summum de ce
sommet judiciaire violent mais je crois
qu'il faut que la justice puisse exercer
par des sanctions du coi à la sanction
mais qui permettent choix éducatif
commun sanctions éducatives
voilà tout à fait puisque nos prisons
est ce que nos prisons ne sont pas le
creuset de tous nos malheurs ah je crois
que très souvent les la prison n'est pas
la bonne solution ça c'est clair quand
on voit qu condamne à des années de
prison était tel individu tel ou tel
femme qu'est ce qui fait qu'un pédophile
coma qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'un
pédophile mais ben justement la prison
ne va pas permettre aux pédophiles de se
restructurer de ce sacre est davantage
dans la société donc je vois qu'il faut
préparer il peut y avoir des peines
privatives de liberté mais il faut pas
que ce soit le
la définition de la sanction je crois
que justement après des années de prison
l'individu sont encore moins capable de
s'insérer la sanction doit être un
facteur d'insertion bon alors en
fonction de ça il ya toute une éducation
il ya ya oui bah il ya tout de même des
institutions qui sont qui peuvent
accueillir des personnes en difficulté
pour leur permettre de trouver le bon
chemin
quand on voit qu'en france que le budget
du ministère de la justice si peu on va
dire si mal achalandés est-ce que c'est
pas fait à dessein
je sais pas mais je sais pas j'avoue je
sais pas je marque là encore ça fait
partie de tout le système bientôt des
espèces de
de fatalité qui fait qu' on est toujours
dans le même sens on est toujours dans
ce recours à la violence en croyant que
c'est cela qui va résoudre les problèmes
alors que ça ne fait que les aggraver
alors c'est vrai que le système
judiciaire là aussi elle est dans cette
dynamique
négative parce que cette justice à deux
vitesses cette justice pour les élites
et cette justice pour le peuple n'est
pas vecteur de violon si basso quasi ce
cosi
qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est ce qu'on
fait on essaie d'abord de prendre
conscience de la réalité de l'exprimer
et de parfois de contester telle ou
telle décision de justice bon de
permettre à tel ou tel qui est victime
de ces sanctions de les refuser
question internet connaissez vous gênez
sharp institué le bernstein je suis un
ami jean jacques nous sommes rencontrés
à plusieurs reprises en france ou
ailleurs dans des colloques et
souvent en effet on associe nos noms
j'ai un livre qui a d'être traduits aux
états unis
keita livres de philosophie jean charles
7 ans essentiellement consacré à la
stratégie mais nous avons la même
conception en effet de la stratégie de
l'action non violente
oui
c'est coup la stratégie non violente
alors la stratégie de l'action non
violente c'est précisément de je parlais
de
non-coopération très souvent ce sera
précisément de dire la justice est de
refuser de coopérer avec tous les relais
qu'elle peut avoir dans la société dans
la culture dans la société dans les
institutions vous payez des impôts
au jeu j'ai pas de salaire vous
connaissez le principe est ce que les
gens doivent arrêter de payer leurs
impôts alors nous avons déjà mené des
actions de refus de la peau
vraiment par rapport à la halle armes
nucléaires et
je pense que la cohérence la cohérence
serait en effet de deux juges et
l'emploi qui est fait de l'argent de nos
impôts donc de refuser une part de
l'impôt par exemple qui va à l'armement
nucléaire ça oui je suis tout à fait
partisan quel regard la société civile
doit avoir par rapport à ses
fonctionnaires parce que les
fonctionnaires sont les passeurs dessous
d'un système qui écrase ou est-ce que
les fonctionnaires sont les prisonniers
de ce système bah là aussi je voudrais
civile et soumis à ce système ben je
voudrais méfier d'un jugement qui vaut
globale si vous voulez un peu raciste
sur l'ensemble des fonctionnaires quand
tout de même qui a des fonctionnaires
qui font aussi un peu de résistance qui
parfois font de la désobéissance arrive
donc voilà même si là encore c'est vrai
que la la la la dynamique là là il ya
une
dynamique négative qui pourrait incliner
les fonctionnaires à se soumettre en
effet à collaborer avec la justice mais
là encore il n'ya pas de fans n'y a pas
de fatalité
vous votez
je vote oui
je vous croyez ou foot
ça peut avoir tout de même un impact
ne serait ce que pour éliminer tel ou
tel candidate bon
vous voyez de qui je parle jean luc
mélenchon commun de jean-luc mélenchon
j'ai parlé de candidates voilà aux
dernières élections il y avait une
candidate est un candidat j'ai voté pour
le candidat
emmanuel macron voilà bah oui je n'avais
pas le choix bon alors les leviers pas
le choix
vous pratiquez ce fameux vote utile ah
ben je sais comment vote soit utile oui
bien sûr alors l'expression quel beau
mais j'essaie de mon vote soit utile
donc de réussir les bottes inutiles ont
même plus que ça des des votes
dommageable alors oui mais une façon
l'élection est tout de même une un
passage
normal de la vie en société
la majorité peut se tromper mais comment
prendre des décisions sinon par
l'expression d'une majorité ce que vous
croyez à la grève du vote
dans telle ou telle situation peut-être
mais je n'en fais pas un principe absolu
en tous les cas pas ce que ça pourrait
être aussi la la la la tentation de se
mettre en dehors de la réalité de de
cultiver un certain purisme qui ne
m'intéresse pas
aurait-on pu renverser la monarchie
absolue avec une révolution non violente
à c'est le genre de question qui est
à laquelle est difficile de répondre
il faudrait voir d'ailleurs si est ce
qu'il ya eu que la violence qui a
mais à hama la monarchie absolue oui je
le veux comment la veuve oui quoi qui a
eu tout de même tout un processus aussi
institutionnels culturels qui a fait
qu'on a pu dépasser ces problématiques
thomas dit là encore je ne crois pas
qu'il ya une fatalité de la violence
est-ce que vous avez d'ouvragé nous
conseillez que vous n'avez pas écrit
ravi de voir que je n'ai pas écrit les
motifs de chf et
le livre que vous avez relu le plus
souvent
[Rires]
c'est peut être quand même les livres de
gandhi mais grandissait ses 90 volume en
anglais de plus de 500 pages chacun très
mal traduit donc mais pas traduit même
été introduit et ceux qui sont traduits
sont mal traduit donc j'ai pas terminé
ma lecture de gandhi si vous voulez donc
je continue ma lecture de gandhi
en espérant que je la finir et un jour
mais
ça reste quand même mon inspiration
majeure
question internet comment expliquer la
violence de certains moines bouddhistes
ont bien manille alors oui il faudrait
l'expliquer par là certainement la
sociologie la réalité de la géopolitique
oui mais c'est vrai en même temps c'est
une contradiction totale parce que le
bouddhisme est fondée aussi sur la non
violence bon peut-être aussi clairement
que le christianisme il ya toute une
tradition non violente dans le
bouddhisme qui est mise à mal aussi par
les institutions et
instrumentalisé comment instrumentalisé
instrumentalisé oui alors c'est le cas
notamment de ce leader bear marquis qui
justifie la violence à l'encontre d'une
minorité musulmane ce problème des
religions est terrible finalement parce
que les religions qui devraient s'unir
pour faire valoir la non-violence
finissent trop souvent les unes contre
les autres par les moyens de la violence
ce qu'il renie totalement est ce qui ne
serait pas un ton de renier toute forme
de religion
alors tout dépend si on n'entend pas
religion si la religion c'est la
relation à dieu tout puissant
probablement oui mais si la religion
c'est une spiritualité qui essaie de
faire valoir l'enseignement spirituel de
certains maîtres comme bouddha ou jésus
alors en ce qui concerne
l'islam c'est plus compliqué parce que
c'est vrai que là aussi il faut être
très prudent parce que bon mais j'ai
étudié de près l'islam il y a dans le
coran des versets qui justifie la
violence et la guerre c'est un
conditions dans lesquelles je pourrais
vous donner les références je les ai
sûrement dans mon courant mais je ne
sais pas par coeur comme ça mais il y en
ait fait
donc les musulmans peuvent
légitimement du mal également se réfère
à tel ou tel verset du coran pour
justifier la violence donc il faut aussi
une rupture par rapport au courant
pour
pacifier l'islam est-ce qu'il faut
renoncer à notre propre hymne national
alors
est-ce que la marseillaise n'est pas une
nounou de la violence probablement
probablement
et puis là encore que ce soit le chant
patriotique que l'on n'apprend dans les
écoles qui ont fait chanter aux enfants
c 'est une forme de tri nations bien sûr
dans documents oui merci merci bien sûr
je crois que là encore on se rit fait à
toute une tradition une culture de
violence guerrière
qui fait que bien sûr il ya eu d'aidé
des héros dans la guerre pendant la
dernière guerre ceux qui ont combattu le
nazisme
par la viola je ne vais pas les
condamner mais vouloir idéologie d par
rapport à ça je crois que ce que c'est
tout à fait négatifs ou est-ce que la
non violence n'est pas un mouvement de
la chance fin de compte bon vous allez
pas n'espérez pas que
je vais essayer de vous faire sortir de
vos gonds mais ça m'a l'air un possible
bain pas comme ça tous les cas alors que
certains mais même je sais pas c'est pas
la majorité je pense parce que encore
une fois l'annoncé gandhi et martin
luther king c'est tolstoï qui sont des
hommes éminemment courageux qui est qui
va dire que j étais à l'âge matin le
ring était un large non il faudrait
avoir une conception d'abord de
l'adullact du courage de la violence qui
n'est pas non plus le fait de tout le
monde non je ne crois pas que soit
l'idée majoritaire de penser que la non
violence est le fait de la jeune acheter
jamais là la non violence est toujours
une résistance un de résistants risque
et donc c'est le contraire de la lah
fier il faut du courage pour se
sacrifier il faut du courage tout à fait
il faut du courage pour résister parce
qu'il ya toujours des inconvénients
majeurs qui peuvent vous arriver
non pas qu'ils sont
négatifs en soit
j'ai envoyé mon livret militaire est
officier de réserve et je n'ai eu que de
la prison avec sursis j'ai fait appel
parce que j'espérais condamné à de la
prison ferme et plus ah ben et plus va
déjà la prison fait bon et est
intéressant parce que ça aurait permis
davantage de m'exprimer devant les
médias de faire connaître mon engagement
seulement les juges ont fait le même
raisonnement que moi pendant l'appel et
ils n'ont pas voulu me mettre en prison
question internet c'est un coup d'état
non violent est il possible
générale illimitée point d'interrogation
un siège des citoyens contre leurs
oppresseurs mais assure alors c'est
théoriquement possible alors après bien
sûr c'est compliqué il va pas rêver mais
bien sûr que il est possible de pouvoir
mobiliser la population dans justement
dans une opération de désobéissance
civile par rapport à l'ordre établi qui
soit une révolution mais il ya une
question d'internet encore qu'ils
interviewaient pour approfondir la
pratique de l'action non violente de la
deus désobéissance civile
on va nous sommes quand même plusieurs
pannes ou nous avons donc créé un
mouvement qui s'appelle le magma poney
la nati non violente
plusieurs d'entre nous ont écrit des
livres donc je pense par mamie alain
refalo qui avait traduit un livre de
tolstoï oui nous sommes quand même
plusieurs à pouvoir être approché pour
parler de la désobéissance civile et de
la non violence
est-ce que vous avez des questions à
nous poser
à ben j'allais dire que vous ensemble
après sept heures de conversation j'ai
pas compris suis moi que vous ensemble
de la non violence
après sept heures de conversation est ce
que vous pensez que les faits il ya là
quelque chose de crédible ou est-ce que
vous gardez vos réserves
c'est une question personnelle ou pour
la communauté aubin elle est pour la
communauté mais c'est vous qui avez le
micro
c'est nécessaire
gg c'est john lennon qui disait que le
pouvoir politique avait besoin de cette
violence pour légitimer son action
violente contre le peuple
je pense que le mouvement non violent et
nécessaire pas suffisamment médiatisé
pour pas suffisamment au sexy
mais il faut que la jeune génération s'y
attellent c'est pour ça qu'on est venu
nous voir mais je suis heureux vous avez
raison c'est pas assez médiatisé bien
sûr il faudrait que on voit davantage
présentes dans les médias alors c'est
pas en tête de tout rien n'a encore les
bons et probablement qui est un progrès
qui se fait mais il ya beaucoup à faire
encore bien sécurisé on a une dernière
question vous posez c'est même pas une
question c'est un conseil pour les
jeunes générations vous laisser une
bouteille à la mer sur internet qui va
devenir impérissable grâce à l'internet
laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations qui nous regardent qui vous
regardent rond dans un futur peut-être
vous des passants
le conseil ça serait justement de
prendre conscience
de la culture de violence qui voudrait
s'imposer à nous est de prendre
conscience des possibilités d'une
culture de la non violence elle encore
finalement je serai pas original je
dirais aux jeunes lisent et gandhi lisez
martin luther king jean-marie mur merci
merci à vous clap de fin
[Musique]
m
e